you're not giving us any new cases
there's nothing to work on
[Music]
so this is how it ends well every ending
is a new beginning
another great Gina linetti entrance you
better savor these while you still can
Sarge Gina I am not in the mood
how are you so unaffected by all this
because I have already moved on I'm
devoting my energy to my new project
Gina's on it's a one-stop online portal
for my legions of followers
speaking of heel What's Up G hive its
Queen G I'm bored at work so I'm gonna
prank all my coworkers that sounds like
a bad idea for an already crappy day
fine Sarge I won't do it I will do it so
you can count this as my first prank I
guess unofficially mr. Haverford on the
morning of your crash were you alone in
your car yes your honor this was an
accident plain and simple I don't want
to put words in your mouth but case
dismissed and you were texting at the
time correct how dare you sir I was
tweeting please read Exhibit C the
transcript of your Twitter page leading
up to and immediately following your
crash 9:15
four green lights in a row hashtag
blessed 917 Drive faster blue Civic damn
hashtag soccer moms 918 got a pass this
lady on the edge Kirsch that's when I
hit the fire hydrant
sorry allegedly at the 409 20 just hit a
fire hydrant but I survived hashtag
unbreakable hashtag what's mr. glass up
to these days hashtag why no sequel
prosecution rests your honor mr.
Haverford you have a problem keeping
your eyes on the road and off your
electronic devices I'm gonna tailor a
punishment to fit the crime one week
without screens no phone tablets
computers television anything no please
send me to jail he slip-ups and that
week becomes a month turn in your phone
please fine one last tweet bailiff
press send bailiff press send
LaRon James we still on for breakfast
your hour and a half late for work yeah
sorry I can't use my GPS but I figured
it out I just drove around in circles
until I saw something familiar you live
three miles from here three point four
according to my GPS which I used to use
every day
I hate you screens for a week big deal
I'm adapting I built a real life
Pinterest board I really wish you click
does oh my god Jerry when you check your
email you go to AltaVista and type
please go to yahoo.com well how else
would I do it you'll have your email
bookmarked do you have any bookmarks
what's pockmarks God Jerry you'll
deserve the Internet
did you know we got that file I need a
captain old sign Gina hasn't taken her
eyes off the phone in two hours first
person to make her look up wins the pot
I'm in that which improves someone's
manners double score sorry guys I got
this in the bag I used to have to
distract her from a phone all the time
when we were smooshing booties yeah hey
girl Oh catch you later
mid-morning dance party
she's dancing even better than normal oh
my god did you hear that george w bush
died Gina may never look at another real
human being again she's unbeatable know
about that Terrence Jeffords are you
kidding me change my relationship status
to it's complicated pony up y'all
it's for life hey baby no no no it was a
mistake my thumb slipped it I have to go
home going crazy Ron
lypa that's Creed's is pointless I made
an iPhone out of paper it's not the same
though this is the work of a lunatic you
need to detox tomorrow we'll go to my
cabin in the woods it's so far away from
civilization The Electric Company is not
even aware there's a structure there
thanks Ron and hey can you give me a
ride after work there's no chance I can
find my way home
Bracey y'allselves cuz jakey is back
don't everybody mind me at once we can
high-five one at a time oh I see no
response little welcome back to the
precinct hazing who's behind this cute
little prank yes kill yourself okay I
told you negative has everyone a little
down yeah that's because you don't get
to sleep see your loved ones feel the
Sun do anything that brings you joy
that's all I personally like the night
shift you know who else is up right now
murders armed robbers Australians it's
an all new demographic for me to conquer
I already have third most followers
behind Iggy Azalea and the perth zoo
wallaby Kim well that's pretty good it's
not just good Jake it's bonza Wikipedia
mankind's greatest invention you can
learn about anything
take Ray J for example we all know he's
a singer he's Brandy's brother and he
was in that classic sex tape with Kim
Kardashian but did you also know he's
Snoop Dogg's cousin and he was in the 96
Tim Burton movie Mars Attacks suddenly
you're all the Mars Attacks page
I love gchat did you talk to anybody I
hit up Brad Pitt wasn't the actor sexy a
guy named Brad
that's a teacher in Pittsburgh we don't
have a lot in common we chat quite a bit
emoji our little cartoons you text
instead of words instead of saying what
up boo
you can type what up and then a cute
little ghost cuz that means me there's
even a little Indian guy but he has a
turban on which i think is racist but
the asian guy also has a racist hat on
and it's like hold up didn't Japanese
people invent this podcasts there are a
million of them and they're all amazing
jean-ralphio no I have one called not
your average podcast where we read
different kinds of nachos okay that's
enough no more talking
what's all this it's an after-work hang
just trying to turn up as it were we got
snacks games decorations chairs its
chairs cool
maybe we can mill around and small talk
about how some of us are big lying liars
who lie all the time like a bunch of
liars Rosa I don't think that's good
party combo maybe we should just name
our favorite sailing not I'll start the
bowline how about some tunes cool
merry-go-round music yeah John Philip
Sousa the Skrillex of his day come on
people hit the dance floor have a good
time why is no one having a good time I
specifically requested it Gina why'd you
dancing
I can't I'm in the middle of a feud with
the that's not a nice guy from Crocodile
Dundee it's being a real [ __ ] fine this
is a great idea fresh air no screams I'm
getting really good at chopping wood -
you're a regular Paul Bunyan oh I got
strong by the wood oh no it's a splinter
I need to get on WebMD now I need an
iPhone or Samsung Galaxy something with
four G's there's no time for the edge
Network what are you doing Wow got it I
still think we should find a computer
and Google sterilization techniques yeah
I have a new idea you need to purge all
of this garbage from your system talk
about all the things you do on those
screens and let the words just float
away into the fresh air and then we will
be done okay where's the shot every day
I start by hitting up Facebook Twitter
Tumblr and Instagram sometimes I like to
throw in LinkedIn for the professional
show ADIZ see that was easy
then I like to go on reddit right it's
great cuz it has all the important links
you need in honor of Halloween the city
manager's office will be throwing a
scary movie night in the courtyard
tonight's film is the 1986 horror camp
classic death canoe for murder at blood
Lake seriously that's the best one I
hope no one Minds if I live tweet this
[ __ ] I am coming dressed as my greatest
fear because dr. Richard Nygard feels
that I should face my fears instead of
running from them he
very wise I see him five times a week he
holds my life in his hand like a fragile
little bird see the night it's blood
lake
now I missed the first three death canoe
films why exactly is a death canoe is a
tip over easily read my Twitter feed I
live tweeted the first three this
morning in preparation in the fifth one
the canoes actually the hero
it's crazy twist fun I'm just saying you
should have put spoiler alert on all
those death canoe tweets also not safe
for work you know a lot of what you
wrote was really profane the movie is 25
years old Morris and if you don't like
how I tweet don't follow me
what are you doing now I'm talking to
you I'm live tweeting this dumbass
conversation I don't want to get
recalled nope but damn these people know
how to pick a net massager I before you
get on my case about those stickers I
already did it Donna
there is trouble a-brewin we think that
you may have accidentally tweeted from
the Parks and Rec account rather than
your own personal account oh what'd it
say see you tonight hope you like tongue
baths you big nasty fireman then there's
a picture of a pair of lips and then a
picture of an eggplant I'm both confused
and if we're being totally honest
Elizabeth lost
you